Okay, so here I am, at the original
design of the class Movie,
to figure out the next thing
we have to do with our code.
So thus far, what we have done
is define the class Movie and
taken care of all of the instance
variables we want to remember.
We also designed a couple of
instances of the class Movie,
namely Toy Story and Avatar.
The one thing we still haven't done is
define this function show_trailer().
Now, this function as its name suggests,
will open a browser and
play the trailer of a movie.
So essentially,
what we want to do is run a line of
code like this: avatar.show_trailer().
And when that runs, we want it to
play the trailer of the movie Avatar.
By the way, a function that
is defined inside a class and
is associated with an instance
is called an instance method.
That is another new word for our list.
More on these new vocabulary words soon.
First, let's define show_trailer().